- Hey, before the video starts,
I want to say thank you to Storyblocks,
who is the sponsor of today's video.
You're gonna see a ton of
Storyblocks footage in this video
because I use Storyblocks
footage in all of my videos.
With a subscription to Storyblocks,
you can download unlimited
clips that are hi-res
and beautiful and royalty free
for commercial and personal use.
You can also get sound effects
and after effects templates.
I've been using Storyblocks forever
because they're amazing
and incredibly cheap
and unlimited downloads.
Recently, Storyblocks hired
six LGBTQIA+ directors,
creators and filmmakers to
build new footage collections
for their library, so
that these communities
can be authentically
represented in stock footage,
something that they
traditionally have not been.
They're also doing this
for other underrepresented communities,
like black, indigenous
and people of color.
You can learn more about this
initiative called Restock,
as well as go subscribe to Storyblocks
and get in on unlimited
footage if you click the link
in my description,
storyblocks.com/johnnyharris.
Clicking that link helps
support this channel,
but it also helps you learn
more about all this cool stuff.
So thank you Storyblocks,
and now, enjoy the video.
See you.
The longest border
fence in the world today
is not between India and
Pakistan, or US and Mexico,
or Syria and Turkey.
Those are all very big,
scary, long fences, but no.
The longest border fence
on Earth looks like this.
It's 5600 kilometers long.
That's like if you were to draw a border
across the whole United
States from LA to New York
and then add another thousand miles,
and this border fence doesn't
even separate two countries.
Instead, this fence stretches
across some of the most
remote territory on Earth.
It goes through farmlands,
deserts, across mountain ranges.
But unlike most physical
barriers that we use
to divide countries, to keep people out,
this long ass border was built to keep out
one very specific thing, dingoes.
(dingoes howling)
- Here in southeast Queensland
and this is the start of the dingo fence.
Now the dingo fence was
established in the 80s.
(light music)
- Okay, can we just say
something right upfront?
Do we all agree that
Australia is pretty wild
and a pretty unique place?
(woman shouting)
- [Woman] Sweet Mother!
- There's a reason for this.
Back when all of this was happening,
all of these continents were
still attached to one another.
But down here, Australia jumped the gun
on the whole breaking apart thing,
and it broke off from all the other land
way earlier than the others.
- Bye bitch! (laughing)
- Because of this, all
the plants and animals
on the Australian piece of
land evolved in isolation
for a really long time, far
away from anything else.
When we talk about the
seven continents, it's like,
North America, Asia,
Africa, and then Australia.
It's a country, but it's
basically its own continent.
This isolation resulted in
around 90% of the wildlife
in Australia being wholly
unique to the continent.
It doesn't exist anywhere else.
And it stayed this way
for a very long time,
until of course, these guys showed up.
(hip-hop beat)
Ugh, another story of these guys.
It's always these guys
showing up from Europe.
So the year is 1770 and
humans have been living
on Australia for 70 thousand years.
But despite this, you
get this guy who shows up
and quote, "Claims possession
of the East Coast of Australia
"for the British Crown."
(royal music)
Soon, a bunch of British
people showing up to Australia
to set up their own colony,
and this is where the whole
pristine unique ecosystem thing
kinda starts to fall apart.
So in addition to what
these British people did
to the Native people who were living there
for 70 thousand years.
- [Man] Massacres, a systemic purge
practiced against the
Jews in the 20th century.
- The other thing the Europeans
did when they arrived here
was they brought all sorts
of plants and animals
and a desire to do farming
and all the agriculture stuff
that they had been doing back in Europe.
Meanwhile, Australia's 120
year old ecosystem is like,
"Ugh, SMH, we had perfectly
balanced our ecology
"and these guys are bringing camels?"
They also start growing a
ton of non-native plants
like sugar, and when they
started growing sugar,
there was one native species in Australia
that was very excited.
That native species looked like this.
It was a greyback beetle who
was stoked about the fact
that these British people
were growing sugarcane,
so they just started to feast
on all these sugar farms.
So now the Europeans, now
independent Australians,
instead of being like,
"Hey, maybe we shouldn't grow sugar here
"because every time we grow it,
"it gets infested by these beetles."
Instead, they're like,
"Let's go to Hawaii and
get a bunch of frogs."
The idea is that the frogs
would eat the beetles
and then the beetles would go away.
Right?
But no.
The frogs, or the cane toads specifically,
had no natural predator in Australia,
so they just exploded in their numbers,
and they became a pest
in and of themselves.
- Hey look, those frogs
are eating all our crops!
(Simpsons laughing)
- Okay, one more example here
that I have to tell you about
before I get back to the border fence.
One more because I can't
not talk about this.
So back in 1932, emus,
these big giant weird birds
were harassing the farmers, and
so the Australian government
sent out the Australian army,
thousands of rounds of
ammunition, to fight these emus
and to kill them off,
so that they could control the population.
The best part about the story
is that the emus won the war!
(birds cawing)
I honestly, I need to make a video
specifically about the emu wars,
because it's just too nuts.
If you want me to do that, let me know
because I want to do that.
Okay, so those are all the ways
in which the European settlers
brought invasive species
to this ecologically unique place,
and sort of started to
mess with the balance.
So one of the big animals
that the British brought over
when they were settling
Australia were these guys, sheep.
Sheep have wool and meat, and
were a big deal in England,
and so the Australians were like,
"Why not bring them halfway
around the world to Australia
"and start sheep farming?"
(hip hop beat)
Sheep farming began spreading
all around the country,
as Europeans settled in Australia.
But the farmers started to realize
that we're not in England anymore.
- No, I know we're not in Kansas.
- And their sheep were
starting to disappear.
(mysterious music)
And it turns out that they
were being hunted and eaten
by an animal with a very
cool name, the dingo.
Dingoes are kind of
like ancient wild dogs.
Man, ancient wild dogs,
that should be a character
in an anime film, and
it probably already is.
Dingoes like to eat
kangaroos, and in doing so,
as per how ecology and
natural food systems work,
eating the kangaroos keeps the
kangaroo population at bay,
and this is very important
so that we can avoid
this happening too often.
- He's getting mad that
I'm trying to pet him.
Okay yeah, I'm done now.
- [Woman] I'm videotaping.
- No I'm kidding, that's
actually not the reason
why it's important.
It's important to keep the
kangaroo population at bay
because kangaroos eat
vegetation and plants,
and if they grow too
large as a population,
they'll eat all the plants,
they'll mess with the food
systems for other herbivores
and the erosion and the soil
content, et cetera, et cetera.
The whole ecosystem relies on this balance
of predator and prey.
- We are all connected in
the great circle of life.
- So the dingoes are important,
but the Europeans didn't like the dingoes
because they were showing up to the farms
and eating their succulent lamb chops.
This became a big problem,
and eventually the farmers are like,
"How am I supposed to
raise my livestock here
"in this wild country with these dingoes
"running around eating my sheep?"
Meanwhile, Australia's 120
million year old ecosystem
is like, "Deal with it,
Liam the sheep farmer.
"We've been crafting this wild ecosystem
"for a really long time,
"and we're not gonna change it
"just so you can have your lamb chops."
And Liam the sheep farmer's
like, "Hold my beer."
Oh excuse me, "Hold my beer."
(laughs)
I try not to do accents
because it's kind of cliche
and I can't do accents very
well, but I just love the way
Australians say beer.
- Beer it is.
- And thus begins another
round of Let's Outsmart Nature.
So anyway, they start planning a fence.
What if we cut off a giant
swath of this country
so that all of the dingoes
stay on that side of the fence,
and all the sheep farmers
can stay on this side of the fence?
So they built the fence.
It took them eight years to
construct this massive fence,
the longest on Earth, and it worked.
After they completed this
fence, sheep deaths plummeted,
and so now the farmers are very happy
and the Australian
government is very happy
because the farmers are happy.
Meanwhile, Australia's 120
million year old ecosystem
is not so happy.
- Not happy, Jen!
- Okay, so remember the kangaroos?
- He's getting mad that
I'm trying to pet him.
- Yeah, so on this side of the fence,
there's now no dingoes,
which means no one to eat the kangaroos.
So the population of kangaroos skyrockets.
They start eating all of
the grass and vegetation.
This overgrazing has left little food
for the smaller plant-eating animals
whose population is now declining,
and now it's also messed with
the natural nutrient cycle
of the soil, so now stuff
doesn't grow as well
in all of these soils.
This change in vegetation made it easier
for wind to pick up sand and
create these giant dunes,
which then served as a wall
to redirect the wind patterns,
which changes the weather patterns,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
You build one fence to protect sheep
and you trigger a ripple effect
that throws off a balance in nature
that had been literally
hundreds of millions
of years in the making.
But to the humans, it is very worth it,
because the Australian sheep industry
is worth $6.6 billion.
(sighs)
The reason I'm making this video,
the reason I'm fascinated with this fence,
isn't just because it's so long.
Yes, I like borders and lines and maps,
but I also see that this fence represents
an overt symbol of this
very European, Western,
human-centric notion of
humans controlling nature.
We can engineer our way out of anything.
The Western world has helped
create this global culture
that says that we the humans
can do whatever we need to
to serve our needs, whether
it's food or shelter or wool.
And in the process, we
can ignore the needs
of every other organism that
shares the environment with us.
And what we are seeing is
that there's a cost to this.
Over a million different
species are set to be extinct
in coming decades because of our activity,
because we like to build
fences to protect our sheep.
And what's crazy is
that it doesn't totally
have to be this way.
So much of our modern culture
is sort of a blip on the map.
We just started.
This idea of going out
and engineering our way out of nature.
Remember that before the
Europeans arrived to Australia,
the aboriginals had been living
there for 70 thousand years
with nature, not in spite of it.
They didn't need to manipulate
it for their own needs
in a way that threw off the
balance of these ecosystems.
So far, we've been able
to engineer our way
out of quite a lot of things,
but this experiment of breaking
away from natural systems
is brand new and we have
no idea how much longer
the natural world will tolerate it
before it really bites
back against the humans
and puts up in our place.
And maybe this is the wake up call we need
to actually start to put into practice
what indigenous communities
have known forever,
which is that the only
way for long-term survival
as a species is if we
learn to share this Earth
instead of trying always to dominate it.
(light music)